en este vídeo voy a hablar acerca de la
intuición que está detrás de la
multiplicación de binomios los
coeficientes binomial es y la
combinatoria para hacerlo utilizaré
muchos colores pero esta vez no serán
arbitrarios lo que quiero intentar es
compartir contigo la intuición que está
alrededor de esto así que vamos a hacer
a + b al cubo así que a ver vamos a
empezar a escribir a más de esto sería
además ve y déjame cambiar color que
está x a más b y ahora voy a seleccionar
un color apropiado y qué tal el azul y
veamos entonces sería x a más b
ahora voy a aplicar la propiedad
distributiva e iré desarrollando esto
entonces esto sería igual a que
multiplica tengo que cambiar colores a a
más b esto tiene que estar en verde
déjame revisar si tengo el que es el
adecuado si entonces es a más b no es un
poco tedioso esto pero la verdad valdrá
la pena habrá que tener paciencia
+ b
que está multiplicando a a más p
y todo esto
multiplicado otra vez por a más ve en
azul
así que vamos a empezar a desarrollar
esta parte interna y entonces aquí tengo
a
a amarilla que multiplica a la a verde
más
bueno el más podría tener cualquier
color pero este está bueno entonces es a
amarilla que multiplica al ave verde
y eso es lo que tenemos de la primera
parte más
tengo ve en amarillo que está
multiplicando
aa + b
porque claro tienen diferente color para
que veamos de dónde viene cada uno
y todo esto está siendo multiplicado
por a
otra vez utilizaremos la propiedad
distributiva para multiplicar todo esto
que está aquí es un poco tedioso pero
vas a ver que al final vale la pena
hacerlo así que ahora tendremos a azul
que es la que está aquí bueno primero
tengo la amarilla
por a en otro color para que veamos que
es diferente por el azul
nuestro siguiente término será
multiplicar
más la a
primero que tengo por la ave
por la azul que está aquí
luego tenemos que está sumado que sería
ven amarillo en verde por la a en azul
que está aquí afuera que lo estamos
distribuyendo
y después tendríamos b en amarillo que
está multiplicando al ave verde
y ahora ponemos la a azul
habrá que tener un poco de paciencia
pero bueno va a valer la pena
ahora vamos a distribuir la clave azul
en todos los términos así que tendremos
la a amarilla
baja la que está aquí por la a verde x
la vea azul sí ya sé que esto está un
poco tedioso pero bueno continuemos más
la
a amarilla
que multiplica al ave verde
que está siendo multiplicado ahora por
la ave azul
luego vamos a poner este término que
sería entonces poner más
be amarilla
por haberte
si la verde x la ve azul
y el siguiente término sería sumar be
amarilla
verde
por la ve azul y lo que tenemos aquí es
la expansión de más ve al cubo bueno no
lo he simplificado todavía pero lo estoy
haciendo a propósito quiero que
observemos con mucho cuidado qué es lo
que tenemos son el producto de tres
números cada término está hecho por tres
números y cada uno de un diferente color
observemos el término en amarillo viene
de este primer término que está aquí
luego el verde es el que está aquí en
medio mira es éste además ve que está
aquí en medio y después del último
término desde a más ve en azul es de
donde salen los que se distribuyeron en
azul pero quiero que observemos esto con
más cuidado mira vamos a ver como cada
término está conformado por ir tomando
de cada uno de los grupos ya sea la
clave o sea de este grupo yo pude haber
tomado la clave y la fui distribuyendo y
lo mismo ocurre con los demás grupos
vamos a ver con cuidado como en cada uno
de ellos o sea en la expansión d
ve al cubo yo fui seleccionando la a
olave y la fue distribuyendo en cada uno
de los términos
es decir la expansión que obtuvimos si
todos estos términos que están aquí de
la expansión los obtuvimos seleccionando
de tres grupos los dos objetos que
tenían si mira observa de estos tres
grupos tenemos en cada uno dos objetos y
los fuimos seleccionando y obtuvimos
veamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8 términos y yo
creo que en este momento es un buen
punto para reflexionar
la relación con las permutaciones y las
combinaciones en especial con estas
últimas y ahora vamos a simplificar esto
por lo que este que está aquí este es a
al cubo y es el único término que es al
cubo veamos este de acá es a cuadrada de
cuántos a cuadrada tenemos mira éste ve
a cuadrada pero pues también es
al cuadrado voy a marcarlos con otro
color de manera que podamos
identificarlos entonces este será a
cuadrada ve este que está aquí ya lo
habíamos dicho éste también es cuadrada
ve a ver este que está aquí justo este
otro es cuadrada ve y entonces
observamos que tenemos tres y bueno
usted lo que ya esperábamos eso ya lo
sabíamos el coeficiente del segundo
término sabemos que es tres a cuadrada b
veámoslo con más calma este término a
cuadrada que tiene un coeficiente 3 pues
ya lo conocíamos pero vamos a analizar
con más cuidado de dónde sale el 3 o sea
de dónde sale este 3 que está aquí
será que tiene que ver otra vez con el
teorema del binomio y con las
combinaciones digamos de tres elementos
tomados de dos en dos
cuadrada al ave y veamos de dónde salió
o sea tenemos tres grupos en los que
estuvimos seleccionando un cada uno de
sus términos y de estos tres grupos de
cuántas maneras puedo seleccionar dos as
para obtener la cuadrada y que esté x b
es decir cuántas combinaciones puedo
hacer con estos tres términos y ese es
el punto las combinaciones de hamás b en
las cuales pueda yo tomar dos as y una b
o sea para obtener a cuadrada tengo que
escoger la dos veces pero las tengo tres
posibles o sea estas dos las tuve que
haber escogido de las tres posibles que
están aquí y es de donde sale el
concepto que de tres tomó dos las
combinaciones de tres tomadas de dos en
dos para el término a cuadrada b pero
ahora veamos el otro término o sea el
que es a b cuadrada y hagamos un
análisis similar o sea cuántas formas
tengo
una de entre estos términos o sea que
sería el equivalente a pensarlo las
combinaciones de tres tomado en uno de
ave cuadrada sería exactamente los mismo
pensarlo como si fueran digamos de estos
tres términos escoger dos veces para
obtener la ave cuadrada que sería
entonces las combinaciones de tres
elementos tomados en dos de ave cuadrada
y ambas combinaciones me dan tres que
era lo que esperábamos
hay una simetría en este proceso lo que
hemos hecho hasta ahora nos da la
intuición necesaria ahora vamos a hacer
la expansión binomial de a más b al cubo
o sea que sería empezar con las
combinaciones de tres tomados en 0 d al
cubo ve al acero más las combinaciones
de tres tomados en uno de cuadrada ve a
la 1 más las combinaciones de 3 toma 200
a la 1b cuadrada más las combinaciones
de tres tomados en 3d a la 0 por b al
cubo analicemos de dónde sale cada uno
de los coeficientes o sea este que
tenemos aquí que nos dice las
combinaciones de tres elementos tomados
de tres en tres o sea de cuántas maneras
en estos tres grupos en estos tres
términos puedo yo seleccionar tres veces
el número de combinaciones en este caso
es irrelevante si está vivo o xy las
combinaciones para seleccionar tres
veces de los términos pues es una
algo similar pasa con este término o sea
de estos tres grupos cuántas
posibilidades tengo de agarrar cero
veces bueno que sería lo mismo que
pensar de estos tres grupos cuántas
maneras tengo de encontrar tres a
seleccionar tres as y en la misma cosa
sólo tengo una lo mismo que pasó con
este término que está aquí solo tengo
una posibilidad de b cuadrada observando
los otros términos pues cuántas
posibilidades tengo de obtener términos
que tengan dos as o sea las
permutaciones de dos elementos o las
combinaciones que hay en las que puedo
obtener dos as y aquí las veo una dos y
tres
espero no haberte confundido en este
tema de la relación que hay entre las
combinaciones de cómo están involucradas
en el desarrollo del binomio de cómo
están involucradas en la expansión
binomial su relación al elevar un
binomio a una potencia y que esto haya
iluminado nuestra intuición
veremos en los siguientes vídeos